[Music]
arcane books of forbidden lore
disturbing secrets in the family
bloodline and terrors so unspeakable the
very thought of them might drive you mad
by now these had become standard
elements in many modern horror stories
but they were largely popularized by a
single author one whose name has become
an adjective for the particular type of
terror he inspired born in Providence
Rhode Island in 1890 Howard Phillips
Lovecraft grew up admiring the gothic
horror stories written by Edgar Allan
Poe and Robert Chambers but by the time
he began writing in 1917 world war 1 had
cast a long shadow over the arts people
had seen real horrors and were no longer
frightened of a fantastical folklore
Lovecraft sought to invent a new kind of
terror one that responded to the rapid
scientific progress of his era
his stories often used scientific
elements to lend eerie plausibility in
the color out of space a strange
meteorite falls near a farmhouse
mutating the farm into a nightmarish
hellscape others incorporated scientific
methodology into their form at the
mountains of madness is written as a
report of an Antarctic expedition that
unearths things better left undiscovered
in others mathematics themselves become
a source of horror as impossible
geometric configurations wreak havoc on
the minds anywho behold them like then
recent discoveries of subatomic
particles or x-rays the forces in
Lovecraft's fiction were powerful yet
often invisible and indescribable rather
than recognizable monsters graphic
violence or startling shocks the terror
of Lovecraft II and her lies in what's
not directly portrayed but left instead
to the dark depths of our imagination
Lovecraft's dozens of short stories
novellas and poems often take place in
the same fictional continuity with
recurring characters locations and
mythology's at first glance they appear
to be set within Lovecraft's
contemporary New England but beneath the
surface of this seemingly similar
reality light-dark masters for whom
Earth's inhabitants are mere playthings
more like primordial forces than mere
deities Lovecraft's great old ones lurk
at the corners of our reality being such
as Yalta thought who Frost's his primal
slime in nuclear chaos beyond the
nethermost outposts of space and time or
the blind idiot God as athough whose
destructive impulses are stalled only by
the maddening beating of vile drums and
the thin monotonous one of accursed
flutes these beings exist beyond our
conceptions of reality their true forms
as inscrutable as their motives
Lovecraft's protagonists often
researchers anthropologists or
antiquarians stumble onto hints of their
existence but even these indirect
glimpses are enough to drive them insane
and if they survive the reader is left
with no feeling of triumph only cosmic
indifference the terrible sense that we
are but insignificant specks at the
mercy of unfathomable forces but perhaps
the greatest power these creatures had
was there appealed to Lovecraft's
contemporaries during his lifetime
Lovecraft correspondent with other
writers encouraging them to employ
elements and characters from his stories
in their own references to Lovecraftian
gods or arcane tomes can be found in
many stories by his pen pals such as
Robert E Howard and Robert Bloch today
this shared universe is called the
Cthulhu Mythos named after Lovecraft's
infamous blend of dragon and octopus
unfortunately Lovecraft's fear of the
unknown found a less savory expression
in his personal views the author held
strong racist views and some of his
works include crude stereotypes and
slurs but the rich world he created
would outlive his personal prejudices
and after Lovecraft's death the Cthulhu
Mythos was adopted by a wide variety of
authors often reimagining them from
diverse perspectives
transcend the author's prejudices
despite his literary legacy Lovecraft
was never able to find financial success
he died unknown and penniless at the age
of 46 a victim of the universe's cosmic
and DIF but his work has inspired
numerous short stories novels tabletop
games and cultural icons and as long as
humans feel a sense of dread about our
unknown future Lovecraftian horror will
have a place in the darkest corners of
our imagination want to take a stab at
creating your own horror stories check
out this video for some tips on how to
add suspense to your writing
[Music]